on this episode sports legend Brandon
Steiner stops by
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
Gary be everybody's gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 261 of the
askgaryvee show
and I got to tell you Linda tone and now
another sports legend Brandon please
tell the vaynernation
who you are and what you do and then
I'll jump in with something and then
we're gonna get into it what's that what
do mean number sleepovers you mean
numbers for what or Sakhalin
oh for Colin right thank you does your
backhand sharp guys are putting in your
phone numbers on Facebook so we can call
you in a little bit but Brandon I
probably knew that mr. your phones are
going to blow up well I know about all
kinds of I know I know you will Brandon
Stein from Star Sports first of all love
Linda you brought the woman goalie she's
the first woman that took my sports from
when the cone legend the legend couldn't
take my eyes off that interview loved it
thank you just love you love the show
love you anyway real quick I apologize I
was blown away I think I said it do you
guys air it on your end I did Brandon's
podcast you should definitely start
listening to it if you are a sports born
entrepreneur you should listen to it I
said at the end that I was blown away
how good you are at it did you guys
leave that part in I was like right you
did right guys I was blown away
obviously has been an entrepreneur ever
do go into this whole spiel but I was
like I thought I don't know what I
thought I thought it was kind of like
pod keen a lot of people are just okay
at interviewing or what have you you
crushed it you're really good at it by
the way your sort of sports do you think
me you and Linda well Linda is under
contract but when Lim is out of her
conflict I'm certainly think that I want
to reboot sports radio and absolutely
like what you should do you want she's
already integers anybody anymore and
that's where the [ __ ] is
these are the people they're in the
grind in they're in the hole they're
into it that's my old life friend tell
everybody you are first of all this guy
killed me we go to the Ranger game the
guy does not let me ask him any
questions he's interviewing me for three
hours so no it's so poor I mean I went
after everything I know what's so crazy
about that I was literally in a meeting
right now an hour ago knew we were doing
this and was like [ __ ] my energy is not
going to be great because
literally nothing I need to know about
this guy because I [ __ ] drilled him
for four hours I have put on a Rangers
playoff game and I like I have to I was
like literally thinking like I thought
you were screwing me at the beginning I
figured nate is going to say at the
beginning but I'm gonna I'm gonna get an
earful which I'm good I'm ready for the
guy I had I thought he had the questions
like written down I'm like be serious
just got you had done a lot I mean you
got you add a handful of questions every
three minutes we did watch some of the
game though that was cool but anywhere
I've been doing this 30 you ever doing
this 30 years I love the energy up here
this reminds me of what you know like
what's like Abbott Steiner a lot of
energy we're looking to kill it the guy
today wouldn't open up the window open
it get the elevator for me I went crazy
on the guy or he runs a building like
dude you're moving in slow mode that's
now how we roll here that's what I love
about this place like nobody can flow
here which by the way if you're out
there you're in slo-mo just click off we
don't need you tonight we don't want to
even hear from you because at the end
day my day is just getting started
and I could sense that your days getting
started I love Ryan I think you know
what I love about business because I
wasn't able to be on the field or the
ice is you know it's just like sports
speed is a huge variable in in business
like just like sports if somebody runs a
little bit fat you know you get a Deion
Sanders you get somebody who's a little
bit faster right you know it really
plays out you had the guy from the Food
Network Food Channel does leave the bar
rescue
yes yes from Spike TV I want a channel
by the way so I was loving that show I
was tuning on that show I love that if
you have to go back and watch that but
anyway you said something really at home
with me you like find an influencer yes
go to that in for to send them [ __ ] yeah
and then tag on right we've been sending
[ __ ] from Steiner like every day all
these influences they're all freaking
posting and it's like that was free by
the way I appreciate that advice
pleasure I'm trying to be giving free
advice every day and then pebble of
excuses I'm giving it to you for free
and you still got excuses like I have
too many passions
I love hitting laughs again and then but
I'm done with that by the way officially
on this side is this 261 Jake on Episode
361 I'm putting the gauntlet down no
more ever ever using the excuse I have
too many passions it
just a classic excuse to not do Gary it
really sucks I'm really good at so many
things and I'm so many passions that I
don't know what to do
classic [ __ ] excuse tell your phil
rizzuto story you know it's funny the
fool rizzuto story I go you know I get a
call from Phil bounce this jet got a
bounces Chucky's kill me at the track
that was his spending money he's given
me by the way real quick I've got I got
to remember my my audience phil rizzuto
is a Hall of Fame legend Yankee player
and then broadcaster like the first
person I ever heard say holy cow because
I grew up in New York like just a legend
guy tough like old-school and Lady
Yankees Yankees weren't that great idea
here's the broadcaster hit a diabetic
bull man it calls me up an eg Ellen
screaming and I just started Steiner I
was scared [ __ ] I don't know what to do
so here's you bounced my checks I called
Gonzalez at Citibank up and I'm like
dude you bounced towards nor check what
is wrong with you I'm coming down there
I come down every what the hell are you
crazy
it was Peter who had to check still
gonna bounce I said well why would you
balance with shudos the other one was
Mickey Mantle good decision
appreciate that by her daddy but so you
know don't worry about Mickey Shaq we
need Mickey Mickey love me and a very
grateful but the thing was Gary is yeah
dump doesn't know Mickey Mantle I knew
it listen we'll throw you in is he's
nine you don't know you don't know go
home we'll get you plus 10 you're 19
from sweetie
Thank You Hannah numbers Kevin the great
[ __ ] but here's the story though I met
women friends in store before he
finishes story up this man right here is
leading Boehner I'm devastated why Eddie
where are you going he's going he wanted
to go in house to I think some big you
know mobile so you know he don't want to
blow up a spot but he's a great kid he's
a Dolphins fan which is a huge issue I
was supposed to see him I'm running late
but I want to give him a quick hug him
kid worse because he's phenomenon the
hoping I get to work with him again and
if I figured if I didn't say goodbye in
person there's a chance I wouldn't work
with him again
so you keep lectures attend was he uh
he's a he's I think he's a true nine
guaranteed the truth is I don't even
fully know that it's unfair for me
direct my intuition is he said nine
wow that's strong anyways quick thing on
for judo a nine from from Gary is big
something you've got a lot of nines but
the main thing is I tell to us I'm going
to make it up to you as we all screw up
I'm busting my ass for three years
trying to find work for fools ooh
everywhere I can finally the guy would
never get in the Hall of Fame was always
controversial you feel getting the Hall
of Fame if you're getting in is getting
in finally he gets in the Hall of Fame
and I got every marketing company trying
to sign for zero it doesn't have an
agent I'm in his living room you go
Steiner guess what I'm gonna pick you
you're kidding me how it goes you know
when you screwed up you told me you're
going to make it up to me and every time
I turned you were coming up more work
for me doing nice things for me and I
believe you and the mall that story is
run to your problems most people have a
problem they all need a roadblock they
sprint away oh I better stay away from
that person you have an argument with
your boss spring Adam go make it up stay
late do more whatever you can do do it
because most people - hiding in the
corner they got the head down
Mila Rizzuto I killed him with work
killed them with love killed with
kindness and sure enough the guy gets an
all fame and to get a Yankee Hall of
Fame I had two employees at the time -
that was a game-changer run to your
problems don't run away from him know
what's interesting about that and
there's a you know I was looking at
Tyler I gave him that advice six months
ago on something that I think we always
will always think about and it worked
for him and even more interesting to me
is the reverse of that brand it's story
is also interesting to me you could
crush it for somebody for six years
then have a problem and a lot of people
get so bent out of shape I was [ __ ]
delivering for this guy for six years
and now I dropped the ball and he
doesn't want to know my name or they
said anything you're only as good as
your last that bad like you had better
come back twice as hard if we do drop
the ball like like right but like you've
got a run of your problems early but you
also have to have the humility that the
market is the market is the market the
game passes everybody by even this later
even this piece of [ __ ] Tom Brady who L
knows why he's still so goddamn good
eventually jesus [ __ ] christ
eventually the
beam's going to pass them by let's get
into the first phone call we're going to
get more into your backstory branding
because you really aren't incredible
East Coast entrepreneur which I am as
well and only get more of that story on
but let's first get this first question
this is Andrew Andrew it's Gary Vee and
you're on the askgaryvee show with
Brandon for oh my gosh man that is
insane what's going on man no he's good
which is my show uh yeah man so I was
wondering um some kind of in the spot
where you know I'm 27 um there have been
you know entrepreneurial my whole life
you know my grandmother bought five
pound bags of gummy bears and then
priests in that preschool but you know
elementary school I'd put them in Ziploc
bags and flip them so been kind of doing
that thing the whole life and then I met
this crossroads right now man I'm really
trying to figure out what direction I
want to take you know my next step of
products is things and I guess my
question who is you know whether ever
just like you know defining moments
where you just knew you know what the
next step needed to be like if you were
debating somebody where you know what
are you doing right now so right now I'm
currently working for a Verizon just
sales rep there got laid off from the
oil industry and actually I'm doing
videography that's kind of like my
passion thing now that I'd like to
monetize and I actually made a jet type
video for use I know you and as you
watch yeah I know actually going to you
like 30 minutes ago again like every
penny I think I loved it I loved the
other day you caught me perfectly you're
like hey like you knew exactly I don't
remember exactly what always but you're
like hey there is no sports right now so
watch you ever and it was really funny I
decided I'm still not going to watch it
cuz I wanted to virtually just stick it
to you without knowing you but I loved
that ever so sarandon whoa you know you
know it's funny because I asked you so
many questions you had some pretty
interesting twists and turns you're in
the hospitality business early in your
career then you saw things like you know
you had some really interesting moments
when you decide to rep talent depending
who had the moments where you made the
right decisions with whether reppin fill
later but you know with the restaurants
and I know we have to catch everybody up
on these things
did you just no no no I knew I was going
to
the endgame icuk it asked me today who's
up in the offices you everything gonna
be the success once at [ __ ] of course do
you think I started this thing to be a
failure
yeah I started this thing to be
successful a really important question
will you end up being less or more
successful than you thought when you're
17 that's a great question I hope that I
will be more successful than I thought
and right now what you got right now I'm
less successful than I thought I'm I'm
not happy about it I got to be honest
with you I love your face I feel like
that's gonna happen with me too I'm not
giving in yet I'm still got something to
do about it and I still got something to
say about it and I'm not giving in and
paint's not dry but one thing I would
tell this gentleman on the phone is that
target target target I think that you
don't dream enough when you got the
opportunity you got a blessing here we
know it sounds like a little bit of
adversity I love the idea of taking a
step back taking out a white piece of
paper that's blank and write down ten of
your dream companies and target the [ __ ]
out of them find out everything you can
about Rosen openness or open the Notes
app and play it down you have over the
notes Europe sorry by the way I'm taking
a bit of an ethical I will have to go
find 10 companies by the way I still do
this to this day like why should I work
with a company I really don't want to
work with why would I work with my dream
companies I always wanted to work with
just being one of them even you know so
over here but at the end goggle search
those pin companies so you know
everything about them every time
something gets written about him you get
that email and on your online and then
started looking decision makers and then
figuring how you're going to go again
foot in the door whether it be the
mailroom the lunch room whatever once
you get your foot in the door you're
working for a dream company a dream
opportunity your energy and passion will
be there and then you find your way I
always work with and for the people
always run stuff always loves going to
work with Mickey Mantle
I figured it out wasn't easy I always
taught in a while man if I get there at
keator figured it out Yankees I know
hard is a partner up with the Yankee
name next to your name AB Yankee Steiner
not going to have years did it that was
a huge to Andrew I think look man I'll
be honest with you like I think you
should spend time on debating what what
creates insecurity or questionings or
things of that nature because that will
help you weigh more than the micro
decision on what's the next
moves right like you're mean for me it's
never been about anything other than I
just know it's going to work itself out
I believe in my skills I put myself in
the position to succeed and and I don't
question things and I think a lot of the
reason I push patients is it's a big
thing like optimism patients even
Brandon's answer he's like the paint's
not dry how old are you seven I'm glad
no worries Andrew Brandon's 58 years old
all these twenty and thirty year olds
that watch Rick watch me all the time
and obviously because Instagram and
YouTube it's a new and I say this whole
time at 41 I love looking at Brandon
because at 58 I know he's just as on
fire as I am at 41 as you are Andrew at
27 and I've got some news for you 95% of
27 year olds don't believe that to be
true
Andrew 95% of the people 97% of the
people believe that bran and I are old
when they're 27 that just the way it is
and that's the part to [ __ ] them up
because if you knew if you knew that
double your age plus four right you get
to be Brandon and he's still just as on
fire right now as you are all of a
sudden you're not crippled about the
next six months yeah by the way I give
you permission I'm giving you officially
permission to be successful to go after
all the dreams and all the things you
want to do without any road blockages
use my card use my name any way you want
also a lark I sincerely appreciate that
and it's quality to because I'm you know
my father was a very successful
entrepreneur and he's in his fifties and
then he's still opening up businesses
left and right and he's just you know
excited every day about it so it's cool
to kind of get to see that firsthand but
I think I think you know I think if
that's the case if you've got the luxury
of that then then really I'll throw
another curveball at you or or give you
another thing to ponder you got a try
[ __ ] yeah like with with making the
trying the ROI right like you up emitter
the thing that I think is always works
for me is I make them win-win situations
from the get that I've decided that even
though
doing was the wind thus I'm almost numb
to the outcome you know the whole like
you won't like you from experience or
this and that like back to something
that you and I cross over on my first
baseball card show I wanted to pay $20
for the table the whole way to the
Philips for Mall me and my partner's at
the time I partners in sixth seventh
grade like we're going to pay $20 we get
there some monster guy that looks like
King Kong Bundy comes out right so I'm
like big [ __ ] 400-pound dude comes
out and he goes what I'm like we want a
table you got a knee and he's like yeah
we got one more who knows that sure we
go how long happy how long I go how much
she goes $120 you know we'll take it and
then we that was these I gonna bring the
money tomorrow and then we just like
start walking out of the mall my friends
are in a coma
you know like $120 like a billion and
I'm like cool but then I start being
like [ __ ] and I start getting nervous
and like you know like what am I going
to do like I got it but like that seems
like a whole lot and and my dad who I've
never talked to back then to his credit
he says they'll be you know it's gonna
be worth the experience and honestly
maybe maybe from that day on that has
been a credo of mine everything I do the
second I decided to do it I had already
won and whether it worked or not the
learnings or the upside of the of the
execution we're going to be the KPI ROI
the thing I was working toward you get
caught up on how much you payin that
vomit you can make now whose needs to
get caught up with like how much we're
paying but then how much can we make on
this thing to focus that much about how
much you can make on it
as much as I'm at your band sometimes
you know you have to spend as much time
how much you're paying you pay it
because you can make a ton of money on
the damn thing and I've learned that the
hard way with a bunch of players I David
Wells pers perfect game mister by $2
didn't talk to him for five years but
the guy was going to run over me in the
parking lot but have regain relationship
with them but I work from that and that
was a big not yeah yeah yeah was when I
business because we didn't have him yes
I have these perfect game pieces I need
to put them on it but at the end you
learn as I waited I was so caught up in
the two bucks because was it you owe per
sign yeah you wanted 35 often
I'm like she's just giving him the
goddamn money but I didn't want to do it
mean why I could have made a ton of
money on I wasn't focused how much I
could make I was poking how much I was
going to pay him of course interesting
panther thank you brother hope you get
some balance per city man yeah good luck
alright as we go to the next question so
as a kid what were you about awesome
always me and hustle I don't want to
waste words about Grover Brooklyn can't
i where is your parkway some played
sports I remember going to my mother
that I need a career change I need
something to change I don't have time to
play with my friends and you know it's
just like you're 12
we're change and to take and I got a
cart that's why I went got the paper
route I started delivering the papers
we'll call other people doing if I was
still there milk bagels everything
[ __ ] shopping carts you were like 200
eats of this thing's rocking dough
ladies man like how cute is this boys
right nice yeah I had to go to sob
across the morning here I was super nice
to Fernandez oh darling but after school
I was rolling dad I've bought so many
bagels tobago got hired me taught me how
to bake bagels bagels got hot with bagel
a notch and everything else I should be
now I know this might kill me guys
everything bagel I just want to clarify
pointing out right now I invented
everything on this whole [ __ ] episode
I'm only [ __ ] holding man up right
now I better be I just want everybody
knows that's going in like quickly
nanocoatings overlaying that but that
was ten years after me I I definitely
did late a minute wait a minute women
this is true for somebody I'm gonna text
us Conan we're gonna I'm gonna bring you
back and Seth and we're going to debate
who invented
swimmin both of you characters are
claiming just claim that I've read that
but I understand where there's no I got
him per minute yeah you yeah Brandon
I'll tell you how no no don't tell me
anything man
you invented the everything bagel no
preciousness
this is huge I'm excited about this Reno
crush this is what's called a win-win
situation either I know the guy that
invented the everything bagel or we're
going to get you I know I know
everything day one what's crazy is my
kids
I've done when friends come over this is
my daddy that is everything bagel my I
think I've done a few other favor NNN
buddy Brandon you are at all time
entrepreneur and all time sports
entrepreneur an all time East Coast my
kind of style entrepreneur if you did
indeed invent the everything bagel when
you die they're going to say brain Stein
the guy who invented the everything
bagel is a nice and everything bagel no
I'm sitting there ok just listen we're
gonna you know you're done you
understand I don't know American culture
Gary yes that when I get take that job
the guide says use the bagel factory on
he's fourth Street and Kings Highway
he starts baking in four in the morning
sis would you mind coming to bake with
me at four in the morning you could then
deliver your papers afterwards I said
sure I could do that I call my mother
you know I maybe literally you got to go
to school deliver the papers I got it of
course I fell asleep in the middle
school and this and that so I quit the
paper route job get this job the night
Baker quits I get this job for dollar 75
an hour huge I'm feeling rich my but
there was no there's nobody coming in
the store at night I was bored I with my
mom when you were this 73 seven money so
autumn unnie I always have my money
stacked up on my dress or something I'm
bored out of my mom you one of those
guys who puts pictures on Instagram and
shows their cash now you're the original
douchebag every night yeah I make sure
but the mistake returning that cash on
my dress before my brother our standing
money I love anyway I don't care about
real quick customer by the way oh by the
way at night is when identity everything
bagel because there's nobody coming in
the store so I figured oh me probably
different sees run random like Brandon
all right no no I'm at any real question
obviously you've made in everything be
go back man do you know I was the first
person I've ever I never hear I remember
this factory in 73 it wasn't a lot of
Davos stores is a route that delivered
bagels everywhere everywhere and they
will not say I started yet
does early I'm 12 years old I got no
going on baby high school 5 cents per
bagel by the way see what I'm alive
cents for a bagel five and a coffee with
nothing quarter the less coffee's not
like it is now I know how much was it I
never drank up which is so slightly a
couple pennies now hello slice of PBS
fifteenth and Cody's Gary beer on the
askgaryvee show with Brandon Schneider
made a lot of progress this is unreal it
now I'm very excited I listen to you
every single morning I appreciate on the
way to walk the walk the word man
thank you brother what's your question
so I'm just starting out a little
business here I'm on basically selling
online clothes okay and I'm doing videos
all the proceeds go for rendom acts of
kindness so basically basically what I
want to know is how do I find and afford
a d-roc in the very beginning stages got
it so you're selling t-shirts and all
the profits then go into random acts of
kindness and you want to document that
journey absolutely every step of the way
great and what's your Instagram account
right now it's at th L shop Journal
story at our THL shop our T yep h/h l L
shop shop clear and where's number and
where and where are you based you
probably never even heard of it
Newfoundland Canada I've heard of it of
course I'm a hockey fan okay good news
somebody here's really good advantage in
being in the [ __ ] [ __ ] Canada
ready for it here it comes here two kids
are going to ram you right now and I'm
going to do it for free it's a done deal
Brandon is such a draw there's plenty of
people watching there's two or three
people right now who are literally and
maybe it's a month for now maybe it's a
week from now I guarantee two or three
people are going to DM you and be
willing to do it to build their resume
14 year olds Brandon and gas
we are DMing you right now and saying
bro I'll do it for free because they
want to put something on tape I love it
I want to tell you sorry I wanted
everyone loved you do that act of
kindness you know every morning at
Steiner my assistants here charities we
do two acts of kindness every day why
not fit into every day we do zero but
why don't you do three we sometimes do
we always do - I wanted you to cry for
every day like every minute is a call in
the ground side good yeah so my very
first video I just went to a coffee shop
I set up a camera i anonymously just
paid for people's coffee and almost
every single person wanted to pay it
forward and then my friend who was
working message to me two days later she
said someone that I bought coffee for by
the large coffee for himself and then
five large coffees for the next spot
people that came in which I thought was
pretty cool help people just wanted to
pay it forward um good doing the right
thing is oh dude I'm contacting you
tomorrow morning I'm buying some
t-shirts I'm your your person my list
tomorrow I'm just telling you right now
your first my list tomorrow customer
Cody I was that worried baby they were
like oh you hold on hold on yeah as soon
as you get the order from Brandon you
need to email Gary our vaynermedia and
I'm going to buy one more t-shirt than
Brandon does don't [ __ ] with me you see
I know what your Facebook me Facebook me
tonight right now so I have all the
details I give Roget the [ __ ] go on
tonight and Gary but after your
absolutely great I've already trunk you
like you doesn't matter what you're
going to do I'm going to buy one more
t-shirt than you and so I don't know
what why you sent us a [ __ ] Facebook
but it doesn't matter because that
because that's the I go to every night
my messages about going to Washington
Church you got a free video dog fur is
coming your way life is good today I'm
on your own you may be when you buy the
Jets we'll get the symbol of eternity
hey I mean listen let's not get carried
away I mean linkle I'm thrilled but
that's extreme I love agree with you I
appreciate it my man
good dude alright let's get another call
Brandon do you know it's funny I got to
tell you I'm getting to know you more
and more
you know I like about you and I what I
really like about entrepreneurship a
little bit and I'm hoping it continues
to build momentum which is why I'm
bringing up right now I like that people
love it so much they want to give back
to the game one thing I've always
noticed amuse you always want to put on
the Young's like we see ourselves right
it's cool I love it I love doing really
good at is I love when I see it in the
kids too of course the game can't just
write good right like like I've noticed
that in you like you love that part of
it right was it a chain I love speaking
of it it's Louis right love it Brandon
love the young Octavio is scary be
you're on the askgaryvee show
with Brandon Jerry Steiner Terry Brandon
I cannot believe in man Molina brother
there I've hit several different
sponsors Wayne on live manage greats
finally talk to you guys know where he's
really from Austin Texas
London what's your question you know
I've been grinding through the same
industry for about 15 years I love it
I'm passionate about it can it is not a
sexy profession at all but it is
something that brings home the bacon man
it feeds my family it feeds me and other
passions that I have but it's a it's not
a nine-to-five it's a sales job I'm in
it all the time so I'm pursuing other
passions other wants other ideas that I
have but again I've listened to you talk
about hey you need 6 hours of sleep and
you need a grind on your second job your
extra job but man alive there's only so
much I can do within a shortened period
of time so and I've got to provide I've
got to provide for my family you're not
wrong so now let's get to the most
interesting part
and and I'll continue to grind I'll
continue to do what I can when I can as
often as I can and and I think that's
the point on the right like like like
life's about alternatives like I think
that's awesome that you're dealing with
the practicality and look by the way
when I talk about six hours of sleep you
know some people need seven some people
need eight and that's fine to me as long
as you feel good about what you're doing
when you're on the field right as long
as you feel good about your 14 16 17
hours and you don't forget you've got to
fix the plane while you're flying it
like if you want to get out of the
situation you're in your only option you
only one option it is to grind in those
four or five six hours that you have and
it will take longer because you don't
have 18 hours to just put it into this
thing the problem is you have no
alternative it sounds like you have
responsibilities that you've made in
your own head financial responsibilities
emotional responsibilities and you have
to deliver on that right every day so I
think I think what people have to
understand is so does everybody in some
shape or form have a version of that and
you just got to navigate it the best you
can and not be crippled by it and try to
be as successful as you can on those off
hours to hopefully create that world
where it switches over where you can do
that full-time Brandon are some things
you just got to give yourself at least
30 minutes a day just to think about the
possibilities and what if a little
daydreaming usually I do a while
exercising but it's really important to
give yourself time to just think about
what if and daydream I'm a master day
dreamer I like to eat dreaming when I'm
walking and just think about what if
because if you don't give yourself that
time it's difficult you got to picture
it for me I like to picture like wow I'm
going to get when I'm going to go and
see like I have this whole thing I'm
going to just hoping with Obama I want
to do his first autograph signing it's
like my dream
I pictured it what I'm gonna say to them
I'm just working backwards sometimes you
picture something just work backwards
but give you some 30 minutes a few times
a week at least to do that yeah I
appreciate that and I'm given myself at
that time I mean I've learned it from
you Gary's give myself that time between
you know I've got three little kids you
know ranging from eight to two years old
and they're you know them and my wife or
my number-one clients they come first
above everything else but it's I'm
passionate about the the job that I have
I love helping other people achieve
their goals that's always been my number
one goal and it's trying to add you know
you're aged gay I mean I'm 42 years old
I got you by a couple of months it's I'm
trying to take that time to briefly
become introverted enough to follow my
dream my passion when I have time on
somebody else may consider like off time
man but I just keep grinding but I can't
give up and I don't want to give up the
passion I have for the business that I'm
in right and listen my man if you're
good then you're good the reason I try
to get everybody to be selfish is the
best way to be selfless is you're happy
and everybody's trying to like if you're
making everybody else happy and you're
miserable you're going to crack and
you're going to regret and then you're
not doing anybody any favors if you
crack at 49 and blame everybody for your
[ __ ] everybody makes their bed sleep in
it you'll never hear me complain about
not having enough time with my kids or
family because I'm making choices I have
friends who only do is complain about
not being with their family that have a
hundred million dollars in the bank I'm
like if you can if you come clean about
that then spend more time with the
family
then in reverse only others people that
are clean about not having more and they
want it but it's because they go to
every single softball game and recital
you make your bed and if you're happy
man then you're good yeah no question
I'm offering every time I often
different I'm sorry brandy good I was
just going to say Austin's got so many
opportunities so much growth it's so
vibrant you're in a really special town
I mean you know Austin is just off the
hook as far as its energy the vibrance
to youth and there's a lot of
opportunity you may need to kind of
reset a little bit and we think about
some of the opportunities that may have
pastors said no to you go back and ask
again things have changed a lot in
Austin you may want to go back to some
of those things I want to go back to
that were you saying danger content but
hungry is that where you were going I'm
content with what I have I've been in
the mortgage industry for 15 years again
it's not sexy I love the company I work
with axia home loans but it's not it's
not everything that I know that I have a
passion for is not every last thing that
I know I've got rattling and round in my
head it's hard for me to narrow the
field of saying okay I've got so many
thoughts so many ideas of what I can do
not necessarily just in this industry
but in in other things as well I love
what I'm doing but I know that I have
more potential and I know that there's
nothing else that I'm I want to do math
you sir yes sir you're not fully content
now should you be and by the way there's
nothing wrong with that and an or end or
I'm going to tell you a completely
different curveball I would argue that
I'm content which would throw everybody
for a curveball but I am like in a lot
of ways I feel like I'm super content
like I'm content because I get to play
my game right look like it's not that I
need more it's not that I need to buy
the Jets tomorrow or have beyond more
covers or have another great investment
or four hundred million for Vayner my
content part I actually think I'm
content I actually would argue branding
your content because you're playing your
game right and so Matthew the thing that
I want people understand is content
versus I'm okay and/or I'm solid but you
know I feel like I'm content yet hungry
because I'm doing exactly what I want to
be doing if you listen carefully the way
you described it I wouldn't call that
being content
and it's okay to look good let me throw
this out you were or were not content
with just vaynermedia before you went
off to Boehner sports and getting into
music there was something else that
drove you that direction some other wat
it wasn't that you didn't love
vaynermedia it was is that it or do you
see other opportunities and doing
something else yeah James don't be
satisfied yeah that's a dip you know hey
man but don't laugh at me I'm full of
fire sport at Siena I mean my company of
god it's like my it's like my child but
not satisfied yeah I think listen and
you can get into semantics with these
words here's what I would say for
everybody's watching I'm just desperate
for everybody to get in that zone like a
look anybody who watches my show or
calls me is already different than me
because I'm not doing that with anybody
ever ever and so for me I'm already
trying to think about that insight what
is it
what why have I gone to a place where I
don't even talk to Steve Ross or anybody
who's done it I'm just so in my own
insular place what is it that I have
there what is it is it by the way it
might not even be a strength it is a
weakness is it that I'm learning
differently I don't think it's some
superpower I'm always just trying to say
what is it and and it's what makes me
know that I'm in a different place than
a lot of people that consume my content
doesn't make me better makes me
different and I'm trying to find angles
to throw at you guys to bring you value
make sense look cool my man all right we
you know we're going to see one more in
I know tile they're going to freak out
but I can't believe yet because I'm
having too much random how old is this
book I think that's about three years
old not so half years old shall we link
up ratings book let's get his Amazon
ranking happy bad you could figure about
spying on me what's calm oh he wants
higher Priscilla you notice what brain
Adagio of Amazon don't go take that back
I do love Amazon network effect if your
rank grows you may actually sell more
and actually then make more of a net
you're worried about her
David Wells 2.0 moment there yeah you're
probably right I'm aware of Amazon
they've been very supportive of course
Steiner Sports answers yeah but you know
something though when I think the book
business-to-business yeah what Chris
what I think I might have to do is
signing with you I might have to be the
first entrepreneur to do a thing
aggression I think I think we just came
up with a big idea
there's no obsession there's no doubt
this is Creek Creek this is Gary Peters
and you're on the askgaryvee show with
Brandon
Steiner how you guys doing that super
well do I can't believe I'm talking I'm
sitting there just re posting and repost
me trying to get ahold yeah I'm a big
fan of eliminated will be on show the
number one town the United States of
America Carolina's
gone okay Charleston South Carolina
what's your question so I'm a sports
psychologist but I also dabble in
politics as well I was a sports
psychologist out of college and went to
Cal State Fullerton where there's a
number one degree master's degree and
undergraduate degrees in the country in
sports psychology I then was a coach in
track and field and Connecticut for
about seven years and had about 50
all-americans that New Haven became the
14th most violent city in America yeah
so I left I left coaching got involved
in community activism started out as a
volunteer started out after a volunteer
making $5 an hour to wear in four years
I was running for States for Bernie
Sanders in his last political campaign
as a state director when he ran for
president and then I decided to get back
into sports psychology and mental
conditioning and do that for sports
teams you know kind of peppered across
the country but I'm really looking to
try to find out a way to it's in my
business because right now everything is
word of mouth amongst the people that
I've worked with and I'm trying to
really you know get the Instagram G
ain't growing happily I'm gonna give
money to spend on marketing or you gonna
have to go grassroots in organic
probably going to have to go grassroots
in organic
well then you're in the word-of-mouth
business and what you need to do is
create content organically on these
social networks that is shareable so I
would put out your best information for
free
on the internet because that is the
number one insight how to get people to
share your content cool that's what
doing I'm creating a blog like I have a
article that goes out about once a week
I'm trying to work Instagram really hard
I put out a couple of things there
started anchor I've done podcast are you
doing are you doing this full-time yes
because I still work with political
campaigns and that's the thing that
really keeps everything running and I'm
also working on pretty much a non-profit
and political stuff is the thing that
keeps my money coming in but really
sports fact is where I want to end up
doing more of my time cause so many
people are going to be having this model
I'm going to say one last time fixing
the plane while you're flying it one
blog post on your blog is probably not
going to be enough volume to get to
where you need to get to you know three
times a week on Facebook in full
long-form so people can share it it's
going to give you a better chance than
one post on your blog that nobody's
going to so I think these are the subtle
things of how I'm thinking about it do
you see what I mean real quickly so
what's the biggest sports team in your
area
well we're exhausting our you know big
sports teams around around work on all
that ultimate the College of Charleston
so I can work with I work with a
baseball organization all right well why
not work with all their teams and that's
more popular posts you've got the kids
there and you know to kind of help you
as well to do those posts why not get
more engaged at the school work with all
those coaches and teams and use that as
a stepping-stone help you get with other
teams outside of Charleston I mean look
we can sit here for the rest of our
lives and spit ball ideas how long have
you been putting out the content on
Instagram in your blogs tell the truth
because you can double check and if you
live we're going to kill you really
aggressively for about well I actually
have your advice Gary and I had an
intern for the fall of 2016
yeah I kind of dropped off in the spring
but this summer I'm posting like you
know almost every day very aggressively
and you know it is helping I am getting
people coming me from that and saying
like I'm seeing your content one day I
had 50 new followers because I I put up
something that was pretty good
so I'm just trying to figure out
I think Instagram is really being a big
help what happen out there
how old are you I'm 35 love it as long
as you're pumped about this breaking out
at 41 and you put it and you do exactly
what you're doing for the next six years
in a row you're probably going to break
out there's traductor clam that's it man
listen I the tactics matter watch what
I'm doing I didn't post that life and
legacy post on Facebook and it's really
long form the other day for kicks and
giggles I'm a big believer that Facebook
is the number one place people should be
blogging okay cool cool that helps out a
lot that's not a lot all right man good
luck I tell you a quick story I started
blogging on behalf of literate you know
I'm like you know I'm not chancing I
can't can barely read write exciting for
sure you know I couldn't give a hundred
people on my blog right I went semi-nice
if you don't register my blogs if it's
have about a hundred employees I said
I'm gonna fire you yeah I have a hundred
that's I got my first hundred and I said
I went our asset list I appreciate that
was going to fire you but could you
please just tell one friend yeah that
cut to 200 now we have a low of 100
thousand is in your signature under
email I believe the signature of your
email is one of the great hacks of all
time you're constantly interacting on
email the signature right it's like a
1999 to 2004 hack that still is so
outrageously relevant to signature a
hundred percent because you're even if
you're a business person that's emailing
all the time it's [ __ ] unbelievable
it's in there like and it's no different
than I mean I update my URL in my
LinkedIn all the time I make she's me in
my Instagram because I know a lot of
people are clicking that and every
quarter once a year I change my
signature for you know I have a sneaker
coming out I'm sure I'll link to that or
if I have a book come crashing it to
follow up to crush it comes out in
January that will go into the signature
of an autograph line you know we are
gonna be something I figure three let's
do this into that let's start talking
behind the scenes let's come up with the
first signature concept for an
entrepreneur with Steiner Sports things
are bad well I would need to be looking
all along I'm crushing you and don't
know we're sending thing on me okay
let's have a club called
okay good a creative collaboration I
think it needs to be like a Russian
sickle you like that Jake that was the
first time first time I think a guy ran
ran that random was born in the Soviet
Union most Americans don't know what a
sickle is Jake's educated he does d-roc
had no [ __ ] clue okay what is it
Barack
yeah okay good job all right nonetheless
Brandon thank you for joining the
question of the day any question you
want you guess you get to ask the
vaynernation
a question what's your favorite moment
the moment a you'll never forget the
moment you won't pass down to your kids
what's the moment that you cherish and
you just puts a smile on your face when
the Jets beat the Patriots in the second
round of 2011 play I went with Jake's
dad the reason every got it as I said
it's still a base moment I love here
people sports moments they favor if you
want life or you want sports I like for
sports moment right let's explore yeah I
love my favorite sports moment whether
it's your kid getting that first yeah
don't talk about your kid being born or
likely getting into the schoolyard or
get a get it getting the jobs Gary Beach
you know don't do that make it make it
it makes it 500 yeah they don't have
everything bagels in Sweden I don't get
everything anyway oh boy family you
losing me kids mother we're going to
really figure out if you attended it
this is odd keep asking questions we'll
keep answering them
you
[Music]